hey guys and welcome to episode 103
please accept my humble apologies for my
less than at my Robo upload rate lately
Union sickness happened and I wasn't
really able to get as many videos in
sort of i was able to get as many
commentaries in because i still have a
buttload of footage that i want to turn
in the future into the future episode so
don't worry about that too much just
keep in mind that i probably won't be
able to keep too much of a very like
busy schedule when it comes to the
youtube stuff in the future anymore and
besides what I'm doing in the let's play
park and things like that I've still got
my sort of the quote unquote normal OCT
three life and a lot of projects that I
still want to finish and wrap up and
actually make into some videos are
released in some other way because I
have basically just been slacking on
releasing anything lately also it can
cover the hype really weird footage with
these ones at the beginning of this
video I like to mess around with because
from scenery once I just get my hands on
it and sometimes that turns into really
awkward things that is the one downside
to streaming I suppose because most of
the footage i should add not all of it
about 75% usually or a bit more of what
i upload is recorded in live streams and
sometimes i do really stupid things in
life streams i try to actually keep it
to doing just building stuff not doing
POVs whenever i want to do it and things
like that but sometimes it just can't
help myself and do something really
stupid also this is one of those others
sort of episodes at least partly in
which i'm going to do some details i was
probably a lot better off trying to
explain what this episode is going to be
about at the beginning of the episode
not halfway through it but [ __ ] all that
we're halfway through it anyway now the
first half or at least i think it's less
than the first half that of the video is
just gonna be detailed placements more
things that I villages needed to get
done that I still had left unfinished
all around the park because I am an
idiot when it comes to things like that
that I really just needed I really just
needed to finish because I couldn't
stand the look of all the unfinished
parts of this park but the second part
of this video is actually gonna be
making a
roller coaster which is a very new thing
that has never ever happened before so
whoo I'm actually gonna build a roller
coaster I'm quite nervous I haven't done
this in a couple of years so I've no
idea how supports that's work anymore
what roller coasters are like anymore so
it's gonna be quite interesting to see
how good i will be at making that roller
coaster at some point in time but that
is not happening yet the real problem
just is that I'm strong I'm trying to
like stretch this entire commentary
until the roller coaster actually get to
build because all this detail placement
honestly there is not too much to add to
it it's just something that I can really
recommend people to just do every once
in a while even if you're not too big of
a fan of it just go back to your old
stuff skim through some new custom
scenery sets that you've never even
tried before like what I'm doing at the
moment over here with Pats carousel
palace and see if there's any custom
scenery pieces in there that you can
really use for your buildings to just
give them that very small unique touch
it doesn't necessarily have to add
anything substantial to the building but
it should at least and you give you some
more details on its that are gonna make
it look a lot more unique and special
than just a simple building using the
same sets that everybody else has been
using for the past couple of millenniums
and that's why I kind of wanted to do
that at that point and I think I think
right here with placing these last cup
of ropes that I figured oh bummer I'm
gonna build my roller coaster and there
we go it's actually gonna happen I have
to add that this in game took me like
what was it about 80 to 90 minutes they
can't get my layout done which was a
sort of reasonable time I like to do it
tiny bit quicker but you'll see that
there were a couple of problems i
started off still thinking that I wanted
to be do a B&M dive machine I know that
I have basically been screaming
everywhere that I would be that mad
crazy person who would actually build a
beam I'm stand up and theme it
completely but at this point I figured
mm i think a dive machine actually fits
the English team a lot better there were
just numbers problems with thats that I
was kind of already have
in the back of my head that was very
worried about I was very worried that
this would become a bourbon 1898 ripoff
which it was doomed to be eventually
because it was in England of course
though it's going to have that mining
theme and it's gonna be way too similar
but the real reason why I actually did
not go with this beam and I've machine
idea is the fact that it just didn't
work out in the layouts and this was of
course also a criticism that I got from
my shortly lake park was that the B&M
dive machine in that Park was very
similar to the Baron 1898 rip off as
well and Weber in 1898 and it was a rip
off of it sort of the problem is just
there are no other smooth pieces that
you can continue I'd be an MDF machine
with except for the [ __ ] elements
that they actually used in being the
Baron 1898 in any case at this point I
started making the beam I'm stand up and
the first idea was actually to tuck the
left heel away into the back of the park
not make it too visible build up some
speed so I could actually do some more
interactions with the parts over here
and the main sort of idea that I had is
I wanted to get something special some
sort of signature elements that could be
in the middle of this whole area that
could be sort of a centerpiece of this
thing and that would also have part and
direction and scenery interactions so
the basic idea was to go down into the
ground like two meters and have some
nice flowers around that have some cool
paths with it got some really nice
shapes down on the ground and this sort
of Cobra is actually the centerpiece and
the most important part of the right and
you'll find eventually that I did change
the lift Hill because the way it is
right now it just didn't work out with
the speed of the right and the look and
having the station tucked away all the
way in the back is also something that I
didn't really wish to have too much so I
did change this a tiny bit but when you
can notice is that I did keep the
signature cobra roll and the little
curve around it's that sort of almost
goes on the ground but it doesn't go
underground completely which brings me
to the points that I might want to bring
up some people while many people think
it is a much better idea to start off
with a signature
or very important part of your roller
coaster before you start with the
station so even though it is the most
common thing to start off with the
station and just naturally build from
there it is also a very common tactic to
start off with your biggest signature
element or the element that it's not as
the hardest to get in to the environment
and then built around that and that is
actually sort of in hindsight what
happened with this roller coaster as
well and it was religious the Cobra roll
that I had to keep over there and the
rest was just improvisation and as you
can see kind of as soon as you've got
the real basics down to a roller coaster
just finishing it up is usually not too
hard especially with a B&M stand up or
B&M sit down where the end is usually
just a simple corkscrews helixes and
some bunny hops and I think this is
actually the final layout of this thing
actually no almost I still had to make
it one edge higher and there it is I
actually decided to actually do
something which i think is the worst
thing or at least I like to proclaim
that this is the worst possible thing
that you can do with building a roller
coaster which would be turning on the
arms what is it called I don't even know
anymore low friction there we go turning
on low flip low friction is something
that I have almost been like publicly
against and just just really bad I
figured because there's there's a couple
of problems with low frictions that I
have like low friction is way too low
friction it is unrealistically low
friction some coaches you seem to go on
forever and then you can clearly tell
that somebody uses low friction and it's
almost like cheating at that point and
the second problem is that if you do
want to make a realistic roller coaster
with a somewhat all right speed with low
friction is that you're going to have to
be able to fit break runs in everywhere
to perfectly regulate your the speed of
the coaster which is eventually what I
had to settle with with this thing so I
would have the perfect speed it didn't
make it without low friction but with a
low friction I was just able to regulate
the speed a tiny bit better get it over
the hills and through the elements at a
perfect pace and that's just kind of
what I wanted to get there so that's why
I use that in the end and here you can
see the terraforming kind of coming
together the basic
idea is to have a bit of like the
terraforming not be smooth terraforming
as you would normally have it but have
it be walls and on the size of those
walls because I think I explained in a
very vague way before they're going to
be walls alongside the tracks that I
kind of sunken into the ground next to
those walls I'll have some planters with
flowers and luxurious foliage and next
to that is going to be where the pots
are rats and hopefully in the end that
all results in a pretty neat-looking
area at least that's all the planning
I've really had so for everything in
this park is pretty unplanned it's
really just kind of blends in the back
of my head but in hindsight I have to
say that I think this is actually the
best working theme so far at least in
terms of the layout of the theme overall
but you guys will see that in a future
in any case I see that I'm running out
of time I think I'm gonna have to say
goodbye over here you can basically see
the basic planning in the terraforming
over there the light brown is going to
be paths and the grey is gonna be
buildings basically and flat whites
that's how it works in any case I'm
really gonna have to end it here so
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys next episode